so once we were in I sneak out and hit
and just put a sign on the door saying
please do not close this door and just
wait for someone to come and see the
sign and go oh that's a rule
and that so as soon as the guy comes out
there's a few people will pass it but
the guy came out saw the sand and wedged
the door open and then I could get in
when we go to security and say okay so
this is what we did and then I said oh
God and he put his head in his hands and
just was saying to his colleague that's
two million quid
[Music]
thank you
Jenny we've obviously met you before and
but for anyone who didn't see the video
we did with you previously do you mind
giving me a brief introduction to who
you are and what you're famous for sure
so my name is Jenny Radcliffe and I'm
known online as the people hacker and
I'm a social engineer so that is a
no-tech hacker who infiltrates
businesses and companies and
organizations mostly used in Psychology
and I'm kind of famous for two things
it's the psychology scams and cons and
also physical infiltration so that's
when a client hires me to test their
security
Gates alarms but also whether people
will let me in or whether there's any
gaps operationally
great very uh concise explanation you've
obviously done that before yes I have to
explain it a lot because people's image
of a hacker is usually a man in a black
hoodie over a keyboard kind of hacking
something from you know a distance very
technical more people don't realize is
the hackers come in different flavors so
and the human guide sure
um so people hacker I mean it's a really
cool title as you've just said they're
the traditional image of hackers is
people on a keyboard yeah doing it
remotely from the distance uh a people
hacker a person hacker it's somebody who
goes into a location and tries to gain
access or remove something or basically
do something that would be illegal but
the difference is that that company is
active actively contracted you to do it
is that correct that's right so I'm a
security consultant right so you know
what social engineering is about is
exploiting the things that make us human
our mistakes are emotions the psychology
of all of that and that's actually
behind most of the breaches and security
instance that you'll read about even if
they're technical in nature there's
still got to be someone who gives the
information and clicks on the link and
all of that's exploitable for me
my specialism was always just the idea
that we could get into somewhere some
could hire us because if we can get in
so can criminals so can people with Mal
intent so we're dumb it's kind of like a
fire drill right so what we're doing is
we're being hired to test what could be
done the art of the possible if someone
wanted to get into that building without
authorization it's a really interesting
concept because I guess as technology
advances and gets more and more
infallible it seems like the weakest
link in the chain of security could end
up being humans right true and the
weakest link is a team that's used a lot
of insecurity but I don't like that
right because that's what criminals want
us to think they want us to think that
we we're helpless against this but
actually that's not true you know people
are informed will stop a lot of these
things happening but the truth is
technology does a lot of heavy lifting
it keeps a lot of attacks out but
there's that small percentage that
doesn't rely on Tech so it's the phone
call that resonates with someone for a
particular reason and or if somebody
just has a good story
um that resonates with the receptionist
or with the security guards and and if
you don't look very
um dangerous which I don't and sometimes
that can be a weak link but we're not
the weakest link okay because then we're
giving in we're giving in you see and I
don't want to do that okay we're gonna
get into your career and all the stuff
amazing stories that you've got but
let's go back right to the beginning you
know how do you become a people hacker
because obviously before I met you
previously it wasn't something I'd
really heard about it's not a common
thing it's not a particularly common job
and I think when you started it was very
uncommon so how do you start in
something like that there's not really a
career path for it I started out
um just because when I was a kid
basically my parents wanted me to hang
out with my family and it was a rough
area they wanted to be sort of lay in
some to be a bit Street wise you know
I'd follow someone into a building and
that type of thing and I learned just
skills just infiltration skills we were
getting into empty buildings in
Liverpool so this is just bored kids
playing around trying to figure out how
to go into it yeah we call it Urban
exploration these days but yeah and you
know I give talks about this all over
the world and there's always someone
usually very respectable in the audience
okay so we did that too you know there
was an empty house on our block there
was an empty building in the
neighborhood and the difference was is
that I turned it into a career because
after a while we stopped just going for
empty buildings and said well let's see
if you could can we spend the night in a
museum right and then there's a movie
about it but you know can we or can we
can we get into it I mean we got into a
funeral parlor as well
because we thought we wanted to do that
it turns out you don't actually want to
see a dead body later
um but we thought that we did and and so
it was It was kind of just an organic
thing we just did it uh and then in the
end I ended up sort of being hired to do
it as well so let's talk about that
transition because I think um you know I
I remember growing up in sort of the
Northeast in a rural area yeah and we do
the same thing like old community
centers you try and break in or you know
without causing too much damage but
that's where most people leave it yeah
and then they go and get a job in the
shops or whatever how did you transition
that into something people were paying
you to do so I was working with
um some friends from the neighborhood
and and some of my family some cousins
and as we got older the cousins started
to work as Security in some of the pubs
and clubs in Liverpool I am and the only
people had any money at the time were
the soccer players were football players
but before too long one of the football
players who shall remain nameless
basically said can you check my house
you know if you can get into anywhere
can you get into my house I've bought
all this security and I'm worried that
you know it's not that secure can you
try and do it sort of more as a a bet
you can't do that so the boys are me we
kind of went and and and we did and he
was impressed and sort of gave us a tip
it wasn't really a formal arrangement
but we're got out that we could do that
we said you know you need to reinforce
this window you need to get a better
alarm you know you need to stop your
cleaner letting journey in just because
she smiles and says I Smiles I think I
think that one and I don't even remember
that face and all that clearly but you
know it was things I had to say
um I'm come to measure for new kittens
can you let me in and you know smile
sweetly and and in a go
um and gradually the sort of weird got
out we did more than one let me just
another one started charging them saying
well you know you need to pay us
properly but they're businesses in the
city center so it's like well does the
offices and it kind of just went from
there we sort of it was never uh really
a particularly planned route into the
business
and so before too long I'd done a lot of
buildings in Liverpool we got into a few
offices and then I got a call
and it was from a guy who ended up being
a client still is a client for many
years
and he asked me to do a job in some um
Council offices in Liverpool
um and I said oh that's fine I'll just
ring the boys and and see if they're
available and he said to me but do you
need do you really need the boys for
this one
and as soon as he said I kind of thought
well no
so I told them anyway
um but I did that one on my own and then
after that it kind of sporadically I
used to get these jobs all the time
having a normal career right oh okay so
at that point in time what was your
other job then yeah so I waited I
actually wait for some Fortune 500
companies doing just a normal standard
job but my side hustle I suppose we've
got a side or so and the thing that
always made me excited and the thing I
really loved was doing these security
jobs on the side and particularly when
that job started to send me abroad so
they started to send me to places to do
negotiations
contract negotiations and whilst I was
away I'd get jobs coming in while you're
abroad I'm a client yeah so I so I do
you know for example run all over Asia
I'd be doing negotiations in Asia during
the day but then I get a call to say you
know before you go home or you know we
look at this site we've got another job
and so and I've been making more money
doing the security side than my regular
job but having to keep it very quiet
because because obviously I wasn't
allowed to do another job number one and
number two at the time you just couldn't
say oh I'm a burglar for high and you
can hire me to test your security and
it's legit but it just wasn't spoken
about was there even a term for it at
that point yeah how did you refer to
yourself when you like when you it was
just like breaking and entering but it
was you know at the client's request you
know it like of course when we were kids
it wasn't but as soon as I kind of got
more legitimate and I got bigger jobs
that was somebody asking me can you look
into this can you get into this Factory
can you get into this office and we talk
about breaking an ancient but it's
actually I learned very quickly it's
much easier to talk your way in or to
sneak in than to force your way in well
let's let's go back to that what was the
first job you had after the football
players where it was actually a business
you know where you were like oh okay
this is I think you mentioned the one
where you sort of abandoned the cousin
and when I eat your own yeah they didn't
care I mean they were like yeah because
for them once it once it became more
than just you know a caper just just
like a laugh they didn't want to write
reports and [ __ ] whereas I was like the
one that was writing the reports and
kind of presenting it to the client in a
very non-threatening way yeah because
the boys look like because what they
wear big security guards you know and
was that the first one you mentioned the
council was it a council block was that
what you said government the government
building yeah let's go can we go through
that yeah first sure I got a course
saying can you do this job and as I say
I ended up doing it on my own
was
um they gave me the name of um
a politician a local counselor it was no
at the time
and they said as officers are there he's
on this floor this build and famous
building in Liverpool and can you go in
and steal his diary we're testing the
security
um it's probably in his desk and his
office is on this floor
it's a public building so people are
going in and out I presume for things
like marriage licenses and stuff like
that but it was a public building at the
time there was lots of people gathered
outside the the entrances and the exits
smoking and meeting people and so I was
able to go in get into the lift and get
to that floor and I could see a very
busy open plan office lots of phones and
things ringing there's people smoking at
the time in an office I just remember
that it was like that's how long ago it
was
um and I could see direct line as I
could see the guy in his office so I
knew where his office was I came out
that time someone came came out and said
well you know can I help you what you're
doing it and I said oh I just wanted to
see him but I can see he's busy said his
name and he said oh he's busy because
there's the conference isn't there you
know like tomorrow
it's like oh okay I said I'll come back
I'll come back and I did go back that
night
absolutely not stop getting in night is
in still open as in while the building's
closed or is it still open to the public
at this point so I mean I suppose
technically there were still people
around but I went later managed to get
in and I didn't use the lift
because there's usually cameras in the
left but it wasn't really that I just
wanted to be like quieter so I snuck up
through the stairs
and it was by that time the offices are
completely empty so there's no security
guards no one stopped me this is a
breeze I'm gonna be paid a ton of money
perfect I'm at Uni at the time that's
perfect substitutes my grand this is
great not a problem without really ever
sort of saying to the clients you were
sure that everybody's across this like
everybody wants this you know it's not I
just didn't even for a minute think that
this might be something that might be
something I should really ask more
questions about
and yeah went to the door door was easy
enough to vote for most stores even now
if they don't fit properly and so you
can like swipe the latch knocking into
details of how but you can and she went
in and there's the desk roosted around
there's like a filofax type thing and I
picked it up and that was fine we're
nervous at this point well no because
one I've been asked to do yes two
there's no sign of any security guards
and I was kind of I suppose not not
nervous I was kind of excited by it but
I just thought it's over with it's easy
and I picked it off locked up and
there's the security guard that's coming
at the other end of this office I don't
know why they triggered them or whether
they'd see me go in and I've missed it
wherever it was but I knew at that
moment I had to run
um which kind of indicates that this
isn't that legitimate right so in my
heart I knew so run out I've got the
book and I'll run to the stairwell which
it so there were two there was the one I
came in and there's one at the other end
of the office and what I decided to do
is I thought they're going to think I'm
running out hmm
and it became a sort of a signature move
because I thought if they think I'm
going to run down I'll run up right and
I'll hide instead and like at the time
obviously I was quite young quite fit
these security guards but they were
lovely but they were quite unfit so I
had I had a good minute or so before
they they were on the stairwell and I
ran upwards
I could tell that they would they sort
of got into because they see me running
and they followed me
and so I only had one shot to do
something and at the top of the like the
tough laser stairs there was a door to
the roof and like this is at night it's
kind of autumn lights awesome it's
raining it's cold and it was a Fido with
a slam bar so I just banged that sort of
bang the bottom I threw the book up onto
the roof and then just let them catch me
right
it's like sorry sorry and they're like
why are you doing it and they took me
and they sat me in a room a few flights
down why are you here what are you doing
and I just played a dumb
you know I just said well you know I
wanted to see him he's politician isn't
he you know please you know let me go
I'm just me dad will kill me type of
thing and you didn't at that point want
to say oh no I've been paid to do it no
no and I just because like it was always
the idea it was always like for as long
as you can do it you've got to maintain
that right because I guess if you say
that you've lost haven't you because
then you kind of it was like psychology
like well you know and I just felt like
I it sort of like somewhere at the back
of my mind I'm thinking
this isn't quite legitimate like maybe
this isn't right but for whatever reason
I just didn't say well someone's asked
me to steal this diary
so I was just like oh I just want to say
I'm sorry I know we shouldn't be there
and started to cry and everything and
they were lovely right like you
shouldn't be letting the side down you
know you don't don't get into you don't
do that do you and I'm like oh no no but
he's in the papers and everything I just
wanted to talk and wanted to ask him
something
and and in the end what could they do um
you know were they going to call the
police or the police going to come that
like what are they going to say I look
like what I was which was a student
um so they really I sort of thought am I
kind of knew I think that they're not
going to call the police what they're
going to do yeah because in their head
they don't know you've stolen the diary
right so it's just like you're just on
the roof right getting wet in the rain
yeah right and so in the end they just
opportunity just just don't be so silly
in future just go and they let me go
lovely right really and I feel so bad I
felt bad you know about this I thought
these are so sweet and they'll let me go
and they let me go and I went home
but what was on my mind was I failed
this task this first ever task that I've
ever done on my own you know I've failed
it I'm gonna go back and get it so
so I sort of that's something to me and
then I just said I said to him my dad
look I'm gonna go and statements I'm
going to stay in Diggs I'll see you
tomorrow
and I went back the same night same
night oh god really late by now and I
stood outside the building it's pouring
with rain and I'm thinking that's how
he's going to be soaked and I just
watched and there was just nothing
going on
that's not man's
and I'm thinking the doors will be
locked this time of night but there was
no one there so I woke up and just kind
of stood by the doors and just the one
the doors was just like slightly out and
did not locked it
I think about it now and I think I
shouldn't have done it but anyway I go
in
War past the reception desk empty
reception desk
go off the stairs go to the roof and
grab the diary
and just ran out
you know
uh and I've done it I went back to my
friend's house at the uni
put the diary on a radiation overnight
to dry it out
and put it in a you know a jiffy bag and
posted it to the client the next day
from the uni post office in the in the
student you Liverpool University Student
Union
um I got paid and what did they say were
they impressed I think they always
expected me to get it right
you know and you didn't did you explain
that it'd been hard or what happened or
were you just like there it is no no
because like this is because he doesn't
care about them and you shave how you do
the job
still doesn't they just want the job
done now years later you know I always
watch that I always watch the news for
that particular counselor to see if
there was ever any mention of it and
there was never any mention of any of it
but that was really the first time I got
paid on my own to do it over the years a
kind of ebbed and flowed so there were
times when my legitimate career was very
busy and the jobs didn't really come in
and then there were times when it seemed
to just be every time I went on a
business trip and took come up to London
or you know somewhere I'd get a job and
I ended up doing quite a lot of them and
sort of recruiting a few people to wait
with me on different things
but it was always
not the main thing that I was doing it
was almost like sort of like this little
sat like you say side hustle would call
it now
until it wasn't you know until I kind of
left being paid to do things now my own
consultancy doing training and
negotiation and that type of thing and
eventually started
to kind of think well I could actually
come out of the closet as it went and
say this is something I can do because I
could see the internet was coming online
you could start to see that there was
people particularly in the states that
also did similar works oh interesting
and so
maybe maybe I could announce this at
some point and say that I did it but for
years and years I told practically no
one except the people I wear to it and
what I did because even now when I
occasionally meet people who I work with
back then you know in the procurement
Department
they'll say well did you you know I
didn't know you did that did you do that
really you were doing that when we were
in Asia and you're like well yeah but
like this is why I don't want to tell
you because it sounds extraordinary it
was borderline illegal you know at least
in my head I never had contracts or
documents right okay so there wasn't
much protection exactly how you get it
yeah I mean now you know everything's
contracted and you know you have a
client meeting off-site and you know the
client and everything but back then it's
a stereotype obviously but probably
people were thinking yeah a big a big ex
military team of course they can break
in yeah but if this one single person
can break in then it shows us a massive
problem with our security yeah and you
know I'm still hired now but I still
have loads and loads of friends and
colleagues who are former military or
even current military
um and clients you know military clients
and they hire me for that reason one
because their go-to was to blow the
thing up right you know of course they
can get in anywhere they've got weapons
and everything else
so there was that and there was just
that idea of it was just a more subtle
way of doing it was a quieter energy and
I suppose it made it all it was all the
more dangerous that someone could just
find a way in through yeah psychology or
whatever we're just going to take a
break for a minute to talk about a
sponsor of this episode and that's
nordvpn uh Conor I believe you use
nodvpn yeah yeah I do yeah so again
Christmas time coming up you might be
abroad with your kids with your family
and you want to catch up on the latest
TV show that you've been streaming back
home but problem is you're in the United
States for example and you can't log on
to British Netflix well nordvpn stops
that it allows you to change your
location virtually so you can log on to
all the streaming services that you you
subscribe for in the UK and and watch
your heart's content fantastic and you
and you actively use an odd VPN yeah I
do yeah I'm a regular user again for
that reason
um but it's also great for example if
you're abroad for work say and you want
to book a hotel for your next trip but
you want local rates as opposed to the
rates you'll be inserted from the
country you're in um nor VPN again lets
you do that to um to make hotel booking
easier and cheaper extraordinary lives
listeners can currently get an exclusive
nod VP end deal by going to nordvpn.com
minutes you'll get a huge discount off
your nordvpn plan and an additional four
months absolutely free and best bit is
it's completely risk-free with nordvpn's
30-day money-back guarantee once again
that's nordvpn.com minutes and on that
actually could you give us a few
examples of ways that you did use
psychology to gain access to places over
your career
there was a factory uh that wanted us to
get in
um but he was the guy was lovely but he
was fairly sure that we wouldn't be able
to do it because they'd spend so much
money on the perimeter so there's a
great big fence in the ad security
guards and everything else and he said
to me the only way you're going to get
in is if someone leaves the door open
sort of like and that's not gonna happen
you know when we looked at that client
they were very hierarchical like people
in that particular business
and they were rule driven if you were
told to do something by your manager you
did it um
and so we just had to get beyond the
fence and then find a way to give them a
new rule if you like we
wanted to get beyond the security guards
first of all we knew that they had a
policy where Miner auto repairs were
fixed on site it was part of their kind
of package for management I guess
and in the car park
um there were lots of parked cars like
pool cars used by managers and things
um I guess are behind the fence you know
I suppose that was what it was and we
saw one of them it was quite near the
fence and we first of all we've thrown
some rocks at it Pebbles nothing has
happened so we got a pellet gun and just
kind of shot at the same place on the
windscreen I say wait what this was a
colleague man I wasn't shooting the gun
until we made a crack
and then we hired a little van and put a
magnetic sand we got made so and as I
said say it says Jenny's Auto Repair
yeah and I get in the back and we drove
in and said to security you've got the
car this is the registration it's got a
crack in the windscreen and security
just kind of went oh yeah it's the idea
to repair it it wasn't that they said
that secret Angels or anything because
there I am with the van you know I mean
I wasn't in the front but there's the
van and there's the boys and everyone
looks very official in this clipboards
And Hive is vests and those two things
are like fatal because it's an authority
Ploy you'd lock the part you sound the
part they look vaguely disinterested so
they just don't people expect criminals
like criminals right they expect hackers
to look like hackers but the truth is it
could be anyone and they weren't doing
the checks so once we were in I sneak
out and hit
the boys went and just looked at the
card and pretended that you know they
just kind of lost
and said to security this is we can't
manage this today you know some will
have to come out oh so they actually
left you they left you in there right
okay they left and I hid behind a big
garbage like um great big industrial
bins
and just put a sign on the door saying
please do not close this door
I mean we've got a little logo off the
internet put it on the top of the paper
and signs it like HR on some signature
and just waiting for someone to come and
see the sign and go oh that's a rule
and that so as soon as the guy comes out
there's a few people will pass it but
the guy came out saw the sign and wedged
the door open and then I could get in
when we go to security and say okay so
this is what we did and then I said oh
God and he said you know and it says and
then we put the sign on the door please
do not shut the store thank you
and I got him
and he put his head in the Sands and
just was saying to his colleague that's
two million quid
but the psychology of it is it's in a
way it's it's a bit it's by deception
that sign is a lie right and people just
see it in and obey the sign but it's
same as true as if they say this store
is alarmed now we look at it sometimes
and go well is it or is that just a site
or keep out if you see it more as a
suggestion
when we're on the on tasks right it's
not that I'm recommending anyone else
but you know it's quite interesting
isn't it because like you said it spent
all the money on the fence which didn't
work because you got through that and
then you used a single printed out piece
of paper to gain access to the building
oh no I drew it I didn't even print it
we double roast it oh right okay fine
but then you know what would they then
go back and do how would they like
improve that security so the whole point
of all of these things is awareness
right so what we're trying to do is say
look you've got to train people to
question more and and to check
credentials more and to not rely on the
fact that you've got Security in place
you know we see it often um in security
we say hard shell soft Center big fence
therefore if someone's inside the size
it must be okay because we've got that
great big fence it's sort of an illusion
so a lot of this kind of deception based
this is the illusion of security so the
idea would be is is to train those
people to be more questioning of people
on site to check those credentials so
not just blindly obey something and I
mean that's a you know that was a bit of
an exception but mostly what the job is
about is talking to people about how to
recognize a threat to follow operational
procedure
um and just be aware of what an attack
might look like what a what a con artist
looks like really most cons of almost
all of them and that's whether it's a
social media approach like in Romance
scams for example or whether it's even
in person they're basically four red
flags what the first one is they'll be
an emotional element so in the case of
romance scams it'll be you know there's
this person that that the person
believes and hopes is that is a new
romantic partner and a friend and
suddenly there'll be a crisis you know
they've been in an accident or they need
to catch a flight and then they'll ask
for money and it'll be quick because we
what they don't want and I say we
because we we simulate this for clients
but
you want someone emotionally uh you want
someone's emotion to be high because
when you emotions how your logic is low
your decision making capacity diminishes
when you worried about something or
excited about something you have won
something or you know I've got this new
romantic partner in that emotional state
you won't make good decisions and at
that point there will be an easy way out
click the link pay the invoice
open the attachment given the
information and that's that's those are
the sides no matter how you'd approach
that there might be a con in progress a
scam in progress so you step back from
it and just give it some time and once
that emotion comes down you can say
actually I've got you're in with a
Chance something's off yeah so tell us
about a time where you targeted a
specific individual rather than a a
property
all of this about social means is all
very well but a lot of people who don't
use social media get a bit not small
because that's wrong but they think well
I might be safe because I I don't use
social media I don't post pictures of
everything or whatever and we had a
client uh whose security team had asked
us
to get into this guy's office and his
phone okay and he was very technically
not
uh sort of Savvy he didn't really care
about social media Barely Used his phone
we had to get him but it was like how'd
you get to someone if our go-to
researchers online and he's not really
on social media
but we found out where he lived and
that's because he didn't opt out of
online address services and we looked to
see which businesses he was a director
of which is public information in the UK
but all over the world there's
equivalent of both of those things
and we found that he was director of a
charity along with his wife so to get to
him needed to play in a couple of things
and psychologically it's like what are
the triggers we've all got this guy I
figured would probably be ego
okay we're going to flatten them right
so fear flattery greed are your three
main go-to's
um so that's flatter them
so we buy some tickets for an event that
the charity was held in and we rocked up
to the hotel where there was this big
sort of awards night and dinner and an
auction and pretended to be reporters
for an online magazine
and went up to the wife actually and
said
can we interview just a few words about
the charity and everything and whilst
I'm interviewing here I've got my
associate looking over his shoulder for
if he goes for his phone and puts his
pin in so again not a technical hack but
I can still find out what his pin is
which was as uh just just as I was Mitch
was his birth date so it was coming
don't use that as a pin and so we got
that and and I said we interviewed and I
said that's great I said can I just
contact you and give you the link when
we publish this and you know
and she said yes and I rang her back the
next day and remember so what I'm doing
is I'm getting to him through here yeah
and I said it was a brilliant interview
but the sound equipment our sound guy is
not happy because it was too noisy and
the recording doesn't really work but
anyway we prefer
to do a much bigger piece put you on the
cover and everything the problem is and
this is an agency the problem is I've
got a horrible deadline and it needs to
be this week is there any chance you'll
let us take some shots in like a
corporate setting at all I mean actually
of course there is he'll meet you in the
office on Thursday at like half nine
and of course I got past everything
there's nothing now is the only thing
was to add this uh secretary was pretty
ferocious that we never thought we could
get past and would you searched here and
she was just
ferocious Rock Solid
um but other than that there was no real
barrier at that point
and so we get to his office and we set
up like a mic and a couple of little you
know little ring lights
and said okay we'll do an interview
and he said thanks would you like a
coffee or anything first
and I said oh I'd love a decaf now I
would never do that right death before
decaf
but it was because I knew he probably
would have to go and make her do halfway
because he had a coffee pot outside and
off he goes and leaves us to set up all
our equipment he goes out and very
quickly whilst he's off the room
searched all his jacket pockets found
his phone we knew his pin because we'd
looked over his shoulder his computer
was open
got us with computer got everything we
needed and we left by the other door
down the stairs so by the time he got
back with the you know the decaf and the
biscuits we were gone and he's hacked
but we did it through
researching him particularly and not the
company or the building so would he have
been annoyed about that he wasn't you
know he was great he was really really
great about it I think sometimes so most
people aren't annoyed because they can
see that we're doing this to protect
them right and we're showing them you
know a gap in their personal slash
organizational security but he's but he
he wanted he was very interested to know
how we did it right psychologically
speaking and the research and how they
could close down some of those little
routes to find him and then he asked me
to go for dinner with him and explain a
bit more than London
I know you know I I didn't know if he
was going to be angry or whatever but he
wasn't he asked me lots of questions you
know how did I get started and how
specifically did I get to him and could
anyone do it
and we went he took me to a nice
restaurant and he said what do you want
you know what what you want that was a
vegetarian at the time had been for a
decade
and he said Jenny you know you're in one
of the best restaurants in London
and someone else is paying you should
eat the wagyu beef
so sort of felt like bads and like I
owed some you know whatever so I got it
and of course it was fabulous and then
and he laughed he said I got you back
rip veggie
vegetarianism but but he then gave his
security team a lot of money
to improve security it made sure that
all his staff and he had lots of
businesses globally got awareness
training about oversharing on social
media
um about checking people's credentials
and things like that and so that they
were a lot more secure
and you know we need and sometimes you
can see why someone gets to be a leader
you know because if he took offense and
being defensive about it they probably
wouldn't have fixed the problems that
they had that's interesting that's
interesting I remember actually um after
we'd met you last time I was talking to
one of my bosses who's one of the
founders and sort of said oh you know I
was thinking we should have got her to
come in and hack you and see it see what
your security is like and he was like
that I would have fired you if you've
done that yeah because I'm asked to do
it a lot right so a lot of the time I
speak it lots and lots of conferences
and big you know corporate events and a
lot of the time they'll say can you do a
talk but before you do the talk can you
hack the directors right which is like
it's so common I think everyone wants
their boss to kind of sort of see what
I'm saying if you don't have permission
for that it's it's hard to really
appreciate just how invasive that can be
yes yeah yeah and the other thing to
remember is that everyone's got
skeletons in the closet like if you dig
hard enough there's something that
someone wants to keep private secrets
and so we tend to say now even with
permission if I was to do that publicly
you don't know yeah sure what that
person needs to keep secret you know so
we tend to say no but the idea of it to
people is
you know it's so exciting and dramatic
but really this is not a it's not a joke
and it's not entertainment yeah sure
we're doing it to keep people safe it
makes sense not to intend not to do it
obviously not asking you personally but
like as a kind of broad brush Strokes
what could someone expect to be paid for
say a big job like the the one you've
just discussed the breaking into the
director well it's well paid it's well
paid so you'd be looking at you know
what a top-end consultant okay
good answer for example for one of the
big four okay consultancy companies so
it's well paid but when you're telling
me this story what's going through my
head is
have you ever been tempted to use your
powers for evil because it feels like
you could probably make a lot of money
or someone could if they didn't have
your morals so so obviously you get lots
of strange requests in this job and
especially if you do an interview with
something like that Bible yeah where
nearly a million people watch it
whatever but no I'm not tempted and I
think
I'm more tempted by little things on the
job than the big things I'm never
tempted for the big things because I've
seen the harm I can do I've seen not
just the big companies that have been
scammed and conned and hacked and the
way that that affects you know all their
employees and the reputation but it's
also that the thousands of tiny little
miseries that that causes so for example
I had a client who was hacked on
Instagram ended up giving away
um some Account Details got locked out
of an account and then this hacker
um took over account now she drawn a
little Bakery
right five years and every single day
she took a photograph of the um cake of
the day so she got five years of all
these cakes that she's built and that's
gone and that's really miserable it's
not the worst thing that happens but
it's miserable right all that work gone
so I'm never tempted uh to go over to
the dark side we've got to use the
powers for God you've got to use those
methods to try and make people more
secure so I'm never tempted that way
but I have to have big rules for the
physical infiltration and my crew and
people who work with me have to obey
those rules and so for example one of
them is you never eat anything on a job
okay and the reason for this is
first of all you get quite hungry
sometimes all right because you're hired
and sometimes and cupboards and toilets
and things for hours and you don't get
to eat and you think I just need
something so we take maybe a cereal bar
um on a job
but every single time I've eaten
something something's gone wrong right
now what you need to understand is that
burglars are and I say bigly I'm a
security consultant just say it again
but anyone who does this type of way you
get rituals and you get
um
superstitious
and I was doing this job in this office
done it many times
um and the various things happen but
just on this topic there was a
celebration cake like a like an
anniversary birthday cake for the
company that had clearly just been cut
and they'd all gone for a drink and
there it is on the table and it looks so
nice and I was so hungry and I ate a bit
of a cake and the next thing you know
everything goes wrong right the window
smashes there was a cat in the office
that do just a million things
so you know I'm tempted by things like
that
and so we have rules in place you don't
drink too much so you're hydrating if
you're going to do the job in the
evening you're hydrate in the morning
you don't want to be thirsty right but
you don't want to need the bathroom so
there's lots of like little rules and
temptations and superstitions I leave
little tokens of every job I do and do
you um little silver octopuses for no
real reasons really yeah because there's
a calling card I think it helps
sometimes when I present the findings to
the client
it's a calling card and sometimes I have
to go back a couple of years later and I
want to see if it's still there all
right but it's almost got me to trouble
a few times because there's been times
when I clearly should have left and I've
hesitated because I haven't planted the
octopus
you know but um you know so no I'm not
tempted to go to the dark side of it at
all 100
and we're 100 trying to stop
people with male intents but but we
tempted sometimes to do silly things
fair enough have you ever come across a
job or you know a security system that
you couldn't infiltrate
biotechnology is very good right access
fingerprint access the story I always
tell about this one is
what doesn't bother me is how good the
tech is I have a saying which is I don't
need to wait on the lock I need to work
on the human because if someone if
there's a human being that can bypass
that lock then I can get past that lock
because I just need the human to bypass
it for me
and so I got asked to do a a bank
infiltration in Germany
and there was a bio lock
and um you can't get I mean it's gonna
say no my fingerprints are not on the
system
so I banished up my arm
on my hand really tightly so my fingers
are going a bit blue with this with the
bandage and I carried it quite awkwardly
and I had all these folders in my other
arm
and I get into the bank and it wasn't a
bank like a you know like a bank that a
normal person goes into like I would go
into it was a very expensive sort of
financial Powerhouse thing the rich
people use essentially
and very quiet atmosphere plush carpets
and smelled great in a big floral
displays in the security guard
and I go up I just walk straight to this
biolock which which our reconnaissance
had shown where it was
the finger on computer says now beep
and I swore like really loudly if you
can imagine these gorgeous places full
of like very expensive furniture and
everything that's terrible like the last
thing they want is someone going and
creating a fuss
so the security guard comes over Madam
Madam can I help you and I like this
isn't working
and it's always like oh God you know
like I said Danny didn't wait yesterday
Bieb and I saw it again
and he says I think it's just because
you're bandage and everything you just
need to really push and it goes like
this and pushes down I went ow watch it
mate God you know ow
and so he goes okay um try the other
hand I said they didn't try the other
hands put the other hands on and dropped
all the files and you know when you drop
a file all the paper just goes like in a
big like pool and he's like oh God and
he goes look just helps me pick one
because just go in go in
and I was just like thank you finally go
through the door and then just took off
the bandage bandage in the bin files in
the bin and did what I normally do
inside that that bank amazing so the
biolock is in and of itself
brilliant not infallible nothing is but
very good but the guy can let me in so
I'm gonna work on him we're on the I
don't need to work on the lock I'm gonna
work on the human we're just going to
take a break from the show for a minute
to talk about one of the sponsors of
this episode which is manscaped it's
that time of year again where everyone
is wondering what to get for the men in
their life and the guys at manscape have
a load of great products to check out
one of the producers of the show Connor
was already a user and fan of the brand
I believe yeah absolutely so tell us
about it yeah well Ben like you say it's
that time of year where people start
asking me what I want for Christmas I'm
notoriously hard to buy for as a lot of
men are but what I would say is
manscapes offer a range of products that
make great gifts I'm a big fan of the
lawnmower 4.0 electric trimmer and
actually if you purchase the performance
package you get lawnmower 4.0 trimmer as
well as a load of other goodies
including grooming and um anti-chief
boxer shorts as well which I can vouch
for well the performance package is just
one of many great things you can buy for
somebody this Christmas at manscape they
also have a hygiene bundle and listeners
of this show will get 20 off as well as
free shipping all you need to do is head
over to manscape.com and enter the
promotional code minutes that's
manscape.com and
m-i-n-u-t-e-s minutes you know we meet a
lot of types of people like um uh spies
and you ask them about you know the
films and stuff and they're like oh it's
nothing like that it's actually really
boring and you sort of meet someone like
you when you go oh yeah you exactly like
the films it sounds just as exciting and
interesting no because we're not really
playing on anything up I mean I mean
people nobody those Heist movie things
you know where people like hide things
in coffee cups I'll put signs on doors
and break through it's the way you
describe it you know that makes me laugh
because I was doing an interview and and
they would ask me about kiss and I said
we hide things and all sorts because
obviously anything you take as kit
you've got to ask a couple of things
does this support the the Persona that
I've bought we call it a pretext
um is it something that I can use to you
know to protect me like you know spend a
lot of time in sort of cupboards and
things so do we need like a mask a HEPA
mask so that we're not breathing
endorsed and a shower cap so you don't
that stuff on your hands if you crawl
through tunnels and things but the other
thing is can I explain this prop to a
security guard if if the security guards
catches me so one of the things that I'm
asked about is lock picking a if I'm if
you caught with lock picks you you can't
explain that away yeah you know
um so not so generally not but there are
some things I like to take
um smoke bombs is one thing so you knew
little um smoke uh pallets that you use
to to send up a chimney okay
so like we've took those on jobs I don't
know whether we should say this because
I don't want to give it away but anyway
if you have if you need a security guard
to run in a certain direction a very
good way of doing it is to put a smoke
pellet in a bin right okay right because
then it's like it's a fire everyone's
gonna run and check that out but they
again you can't explain a little small
power away so you have to hide them so
we hired them in various things we can
hide them in a water bottle no water
bottle put things in there but we'll
also put them I don't want to say this
now come on come on
but you can Hive in a tampon oh okay
okay so sorry to say but like who's
gonna check that so you know you've got
like a plastic so we put things in there
as well it's clever so you know you're
right it's the last thing people would
sort of disease because you're playing
on embarrassing yeah yeah who's gonna do
that he's gonna check that it's one
thing to check someone's bag there's
another thing to actually take those
apart and that will never happen I don't
know whether it's fascinating no
definitely it's definitely going in
um oh God imagine the comments
you had moved into quite a successful
career in doing this and then there was
one job that we talked about last time
that made you take quite an extended
break yes do you mind if we go through
that again
yeah I mean I was away on business in
Asia
um with my sort of if you like
legitimate career me and a colleague had
done all our kind of negotiating
everything all around Asia and we were
on our last night in Hong Kong and I got
a call from a client that often does
call me and asked me if I want he
basically said are you traveling home
business class
I said now they said do you want a
travel home business class and make some
money so I still yeah
and he said I need you to go to a city
it was in Hong Kong it goes to a nearby
city
um
and all I need you to do is get into a
house and leave a message for
um the clients
quite a straightforward job it should
have been a very straightforward job
um so basically I I said yes dumped a
colleague and ended up in this different
Asian City
and what I had to do was I had to go to
uh it was a private residence
and get into the the office of the guy
and see again another address book look
at look and see if a name there was
there was a name in this address book
and if it was there I had a Post-It note
with a message to leave on the desk
the thing about this is it was set for a
Saturday night but I got into the city
on a Friday night and went into
reconnaissance on my own on the Friday
night
and when I got there
it was just a complete it was a very
affluent neighborhood but it was very
quiet it was there was nothing going on
there wasn't so much as it like it was
by a big lake and a sort of golf club
and stuff and there wasn't even like a
duck on the lake making a noise or a dog
barking or anything and I got to the
house and looked at it
and it's empty there's no one there at
all right
so okay this is not so bad and I could
see steps you know to like Bay like bay
doors is it I never know what you call
like the sort of windowed up bay doors
yeah I think yeah I think that's right
yeah those are that's how I'll get in
they'll be fine
go back to the hotel and I run myself
this bath nice hot bath I'm gonna have a
little relax and then I just thought why
wait
now the problem with this is that
There are rules for these things and if
I'm supposed to go in on a Saturday
night that's when everyone knows that
there's a potential infiltration right
so it means that if anything goes wrong
and someone catches me
then I you know it's fine it's okay it's
planned it's a security job it's fine if
I go in the night before
nobody knows that I'm there right
um and for all intents and purposes I am
a burglar
so on a whim and the hot bath on a whim
get dressed for the job and I don't
really have any kit with me because it
was a last minute thing so I I grab a um
a beer you know a bottle opener from the
mini bar and I grabbed a little sort of
torch from the hotel gift shop which is
on a key ring
and I went back
and I go with this and no one's still in
and it's still dead quiet and I can hear
phone jinging inside no one's answering
them whatever and I go up the steps of
the side of the building get to these
bay doors
and I was going to Jimmy them with the
um the bottle opener
but they were open right so I just I
thought oh I don't need to carry it so
put it at the bottom of the stairs
whatever and go in and I get into the
office and it's a great big office
obviously the house is kind of not lived
in as a home but used as a base for
something
I find the name so that's good
put the Post-it note on the desk and I'm
ready to leave
and then I just did cars pulling up to
the to the front door the lights kind of
came through so the office was near the
front door the lights come through and I
can tell there's two vehicles outside
and in that minute I knew I'd made a
really big mistake because first of all
I really question too much about who the
client the target was because I knew the
client you see but obviously this is
some sort of businessman who doesn't
even really lock the house which is kind
of a bit of a worry because it's either
that he's careless which could be the
case or that he doesn't care
about locking the house because nobody's
going to break in
and so I must have triggered some sort
of internal alarm right it didn't look
like there was anything
and I'm going back a few years so like
it's not as if
like now you know does cccv everywhere
people have you know smart doorbells for
God's sake but not then
so run up the stairs I run back out
and I've got to hide from them because I
can see that they're like really a very
um serious security team that didn't
look to me as if I could smile or talk
or laugh my way out of it right there
are certain times when you just look at
people you go there's there's no
explaining this they're going to do
their job and their job is to you know
enforce security
I'd come back downstairs and I hid
and they're kind of at the front door
and I head to the side and moved around
and I'm pressing myself into the sort of
the wall there was sort of a side Garden
so if you imagine there's the building
there's the stairs there's Gardens all
around and a wall and I was kind of
behind all foliage and stuff I'm
pressing myself into this wall and I'm
in Black so I'm trying to hide my faces
I'm thinking it's dark by now and more
or less and they're going to see my face
big and they're preoccupied I might get
away with this but if I don't out
they're gonna shoot me like they're
going to get me I can't explain it so at
this point so they had guns well I
didn't know that then but they were in
and out and then I Heard lots of
metallic clicking and things that I that
was the guns while I was lying there and
remember I'm lying I didn't quite see
everything so everything's kind of on
sort of on what I can hear the cars are
right by me as well they're talking the
radios are going they're in and out and
honestly the the fear level of something
like that was so high because I knew I
just knew this was not legitimate at
this point the tomorrow night I might
have some backup although I wasn't sure
you know but I'd had so many jobs from
that client that I kind of assumed
I didn't ask too many questions sort of
assumed that that it was okay but the
more I thought about it the Dodger it
seems and I you know
I kind of thought I was gonna laugh
and it's so strange because I was either
going to throw up or laugh really partly
because I'm kind of pressed against the
wall and the fee and the adrenaline but
partly it was just so ridiculous and
I've spoken to people since and they say
well that seems you know a weird
reaction
it was a weird reaction but it was just
so I just thought what what are you
doing
and then as quickly as they turned off I
just said the radio say something else
and like you know it you know a
different language and then they jumped
the con they drove away
you know it's so someone had called them
off or something had happened the gun in
the house they'd found whatever they
found enough found anyway they left and
they didn't see me
so now I've got to get back to my hotel
I sort of got to my feet I was a bit
wobbly or whatever and I walked away and
eventually kind of ran and got a cab
at that point you know sort of all like
I'm crying and everything and I wanted I
just thought you this is a stupid thing
I might not see my family ever again and
because I was impatient but also thanks
a lot for not saying to me by the way
stick exactly to what we've agreed
it kind of goes without saying but on
some jobs it's like you will say there's
dogs or there's an armed response or
there's a police response you know you
kind of emphasize this one might be
dangerous it was obvious so it's my
blunder but
it could have done with being said as
well so you know got to the hotel it was
laid down it was like early hours of the
morning
and I just thought I need to drink
and so I go into the bar and because it
was a very expensive hotel that the
clients had put me in they don't
question they know I'm arrested they
didn't question the fact that I was
covered in muds my hair was all I was I
would like blood on my face and Mock and
cuts and obviously was I've been crying
and you know and I just said I need to
drink
but I want something very alcoholic that
a kid could drink because you just want
the sugar as well and I just didn't want
it to be a challenge to drink
and he put it down I'm looking at myself
and there was all mirrors behind the bar
and I just looked like the hell
and I down the string quite quickly
and it didn't touch the sides and I love
her towards another one and the guy said
do you do you want to be here to chase
that
and as soon as he says it I thought oh
my god I've left the the beard out now
with the hotel name in it and everything
I got her from the bar at the side
so like those Heavies now if they go
back you know I don't know they would
see that and they'll come straight to
the hotel but I was too tired to to do
anything I mean what could I do at that
point
so that's another thing once maroon
I am I remember thinking when I left
that bus I didn't put any colds in the
bath it's probably still going to be
warm and I can just jump straight in to
that bath when I get in
and I got back and just the bath was
cold and I just kind of collapsed and
slept for a long time and went straight
to the airport when I woke up and and
stayed at the upper for far longer than
I needed to be just because I felt safe
and then got home
and when I spoke to the clients
you know he's obviously spoken to the
guy whose house it was It was obviously
some private arrangement with them
um because he knew that I'd left the
the bottle out
he said you know why did you you know
you went in early and I said no but I
know it is I know and I said I was on my
own because I was 24 hours early and he
said yeah some of the words there was no
Gap like if data got me that night there
was no getting out of that
if I had to wasted another 24 hours it
still would have been don't get me wrong
a terribly bad situation but a call
either called and said this is in
progress I feel lots of time and it was
just impatience it just looked easy and
this is what I was saying to earlier to
why I have all these rules and rituals
the scope of one of those assignments is
so important and I learned the hard way
that if you go outside the scope you can
put yourself at unnecessary risk did you
ever find out whose house it was they
were comments okay and but after that
we're so familiar with the setup and
doing the job that we hadn't covered the
basics I felt that I needed a break and
so I stopped for a couple of years and
by the time that two years of me just
not picking up the phone for security
jobs kind of hanging up with guns and
not doing anything by the time they're
finished uh there was much more sort of
cyber security and social media was much
more kind of prevalent and at that point
I started taking jobs again and and kind
of got back into it but I needed a
couple of years out of the game because
I got cocky and I got familiar and it
was all too easy and like it that nearly
got me here so or always Jenny it's the
second time we've met you it's just as
interesting as the first uh I always
love hearing the stories they're
brilliant and um you know makes me want
to go out and try leaving signs on dots
to manipulate people but I'm not going
to do that I'll leave it to
professionals like yourself well thank
you
um what's next for you I have my um
autobiography which will be called
people hacker and will be out in
February 2023 with all of these stories
and lots more in it so that's be out and
a lot of uh hopefully lots of interviews
and things that you can catch up with me
brilliant well look forward to it thanks
very much it's been a pleasure cheers
even though I was quite comfortable
there I was going to get executed they
said they were going to make an example
of a Westerner and I think I was it so
so I had to there's a time limit there
yeah if you get caught you're finished
you cannot get caught that's what put
most people off I couldn't get people to
go with me I had to go out the
old-fashioned way